just let me say a word or two about the
conference itself we're gathered here
basically to talk about two intersecting
trends
one is the growth in inequality over the
last generation and the other is the
growth in money and politics over the
last generation in all its forms
campaign finance lobbying and the
influence of those with uh with
substantial wealth and income and
the fact is that money has always been a
big part of american politics and indeed
in in our past our our more distant past
was a very big part uh there's that
famous quote uh that mark hannah once
said uh woodrow wilson's fixer he said
there are two things
that matter in politics the first is
money
and i can't remember what the second one
is um
but of course over the last generation
we have seen a transformation from uh
the immediate post four years in both
the sheer volume of money and of course
the gap between the middle class and the
rich this matters in in multiple ways in
where campaign dollars come from who
actually is in office
nick carnes will be speaking later about
that today and in terms of what the
distance is between people in public
office and the kind of private
opportunities they would have in
lobbying or other uh fields so what we
will be thinking today about today is
three questions that come out of these
twin developments the first is what are
the important research questions what do
we know what do we need to know
two
what are the ways in which money matters
beyond campaign finance because after
all
there is far more money spent on
lobbying than there is on campaign it's
lobbying and other forms of influence
than there is on campaigns and there's a
lot of people including marty gillens in
this room thinking about the way in
which money matters uh in terms of the
influence of those at the very top
regardless of patterns of campaign
finance
or
or contributions and then finally
given what we think about one and two
what might be done
and here i think we're going to have a
really stimulating conversation with
three diverse perspectives uh but it's a
conversation that will really involve
all of you um
i
want to stop now and we look i look
forward to that conversation i look
forward to the key the keynote from
larry lessig where i'll say a little bit
more before that about some of the the
questions we'll be thinking about later
today uh to really welcome warmly
and with gratitude senator murphy
he is as i just said the youngest member
of the senate he has a long
career given his age in public service
he served for three terms in the house
before he became a senator he also
served in the connecticut general
assembly today he's on the health
education labor and pensions committee
the joint economic committee and the
foreign relations committee but of
course
the thing that senator murphy is known
for now is the new town shootings and
his role in the gun control
debate that has followed it um yesterday
i was riding my bike uh through sandy
hook and newtown and uh there was a
procession of 5 000 motorcyclists um
which meant that i had to get off the
road um
and um
and i uh it was a very moving experience
to move through the city uh in the area
just after they had passed through with
signs and memorials along the road um
and i know this has been a very searing
experience for the senator um i think in
a way he's perfectly poised to talk
about the role of money
in politics and his experience for two
reasons
and they may cut in different directions
one he just saw
the modern day filibuster being used
after millions and millions of dollars
were spent against gun control
legislation that was supported by
roughly 90 percent of the american
people
and that legislation went down to defeat
at the same time he came into the senate
after a fierce battle against
uh a an opponent
uh who spent across two campaigns
roughly 100 million dollars of her own
money um and yet he is sitting here
today vastly outspend now i think it's
probably the case that the d next to his
name mattered in that but i also think
it's a testament to the fact as he put
it after uh his campaign that we that
what matters most in life
is the measure of your ideas the measure
of your determination the measure of
your friends not the measure of your
wallet and with that i warmly welcome
senator chris murphy
well thank you very much uh jacob uh
thank you for your uh wonderful work uh
here at the center and organizing this
conference congratulations to pam you've
done an uh amazing job um and uh thank
you uh professor hacker for your uh
friendship in the past we worked uh long
hard hours
during the health care reform debate in
the house of representatives i had a
chance to serve on the committee that
wrote the majority of the house version
of that bill and so it's great to be
back here
with you
as i've been thinking about what i want
to talk about even up until the last few
minutes i've been scribbling down
more notes
then can be expressed in a period of
about 10 or 15 minutes is a huge subject
and i think my role here today is to you
know not give you an academic or public
policy lecture
on the subject that you're discussing
but to talk to you as a practitioner to
tell you what it's really like to live
inside of this system and to tell you
how if it looks bad from the outside it
feels even worse from the inside
and i have gone from a proponent
of campaign finance reform to a
revolutionary on this topic during my
time in public service that all being
said let me just give you a tiny bit of
perspective
i i
apologize a little bit for my
scruffiness i've spent the last week in
afghanistan and pakistan and
along the syrian border and i sort of am
still a little bit there
but if you want to feel really good
about american elections spend some time
in pakistan
so they are worrying about their
candidates just surviving the last seven
days of this election
never mind uh who pays for the election
and what the consequences are on the
other side and we have big problems
but compared to what other
relatively fledgling democracies are
facing today they are manageable um and
so we should go into this day's
conversation with an acknowledgement
that though our problems are big they
are absolutely solvable um compared to
other nations who are
literally decades away from even getting
functioning electoral systems uh and uh
democracies um so
let me maybe spend 15 minutes just
giving you a variety of perspectives on
what it's like to be in uh the middle of
this system and then i'd love to take
questions as many as we can fit in uh
from uh from all of you
i guess i want to approach this from
three perspectives at the outset
the perspective of what money means for
the quality of candidates and the
quality of public servants
the perspective of what money means for
the impact on public policy and then if
i've got time the impact that money has
on the tenor
of debate um so first let me talk for
just a few minutes about the quality of
candidates
um
today more than ever before
the one question you have to ask when
you're deciding whether you want to run
for the united states house united
states senate is are you willing to
become a telemarketer for 24 months
are you really willing to sit on the
phone and ask your friends
and just slightly worse than that
absolute strangers to give you thousands
of dollars to run for office
and i will tell you how awful this is
i decided to run for the
u.s house in 2005.
i knew i was running against an
incumbent who already started the cycle
with two and a half million dollars in
the bank so i was at the at the starting
line two and a half million dollars in
the hole
and acknowledged that i was going to
have to spend four to five to six hours
every day on the phone asking for money
and i remember about two months in
walking to the small little office that
we use for call time in hartford
connecticut i was
practicing law in hartford and uh was
still in the legislature and so for the
first about six or eight months our
office where i was doing call time was
in hartford as well and i remember
i remember exactly where i was on
trumbull
street as i was walking to the call time
office just
dreading it just thinking to myself
maybe i have made a horrible mistake
is there some way that i could turn this
around and walk this back this is so
much worse than i thought um the idea of
just every day mustering the courage to
ask for money over and over again from
people you've never met in your life
and it's that feeling
that has now been translated to
prospective candidates all around the
country
that has you know led to a very
different kind of person running for
office you really have to be the type of
person who loves that activity and if
you're not then you are probably
going to sit on the sidelines now the
skill of telemarketing does not
translate
very often into the skill of governing
and so there are real implications for
the type of people you get on the other
end
there is a new wrinkle though to this
question of impact on candidates
and that is the impact of super pacs
today
um they are having a different effect on
candidates especially on the republican
side of the aisle
in
early 2011
we were reviewing
the campaign finance reports for
freshman republican members of the house
of representatives
and they were
pretty paltry they were some of the
lowest fundraising totals that we had
seen from freshman republican from
freshman house members in a long time it
used to be that when you came in your
first term the first thing you did was
go out and raise a bunch of money
because so you could scare off potential
challengers in your first re-election
but we weren't seeing those kind of
numbers from freshman house republicans
and it became pretty immediately clear
why that was
with the advent of these enormous super
pacs spending
hundreds of millions of dollars
primarily on the republican side
i argue that there is a developing
culture of dependency on those pacs
which is lessening
the
import of private fundraising on at
least one side of the aisle it says not
translated to the democratic side of the
aisle because it's just not enough money
in these super pacs to be able to hold
up candidates on the democratic side but
on the republican side there is today
and so what you may be seeing is a
lessening of the
importance of personal fundraising on
one side of the aisle well it remains an
imperative on the other side of the
aisle because republicans believe that
if i get into it if i'm going to come
and i get into a tough race somebody's
going to come bail me out
and if i'm a first-time candidate in a
tough race though i'm going to have to
raise enough money to get by a primary i
probably don't have to have enough money
to get by general election as well
because a super pac is going to come in
and spend on my behalf
in addition um and so
for a while this was to me
equal evil on both sides of the aisle
today i think the evil is
in terms of candidate recruitment
and candidate decision making is much
more on the democratic side of the aisle
um i think this is also having an impact
on longevity
especially in the united states senate
you know we've seen a number of very
high profile retirements in the senate
in the past few weeks people who were at
the top of their game
running the finance committee in the uh
help committee in the commerce committee
and i am not telling you this based on
my personal conversations with each
individual member but i think as these
re-election campaigns become more
expensive and more bruising
individual senators and representatives
are going to be staying in office for
shorter and shorter periods of time
because it just
gets to be a bigger psychological hurdle
to gear yourself up and psych yourself
up for the next race when you're facing
two years of both paralyzing personal
attacks and
um
soul-crushing
uh fundraising calls
and so i think that's part of the reason
that you see
um senators who are you know at the peak
of their power
um
walking away
from office
uh
fundraising has a lot to do with that
now you can argue that that from both
perspectives you're gonna get more
turnover um in the house and the senate
which you can argue is a good thing but
you're going to also lose some you know
pretty smart people um simply because
they don't want to go through another
big election um second the impact on
public policy so i obviously have to
talk about the gun
policy debate because it's a clear
show of political power as exercised
through money
the
nra's mythology is built up off of the
1994 elections when
they claim to have spent
money in a way that
punished members for voting for the
crime bill
and they certainly have spent a lot of
money
perpetuating that myth since then
i believe that there are
a number of senators who knew in their
heart what the right thing to do was on
this vote
but bailed because of their fear of
political repercussions from the nra i
won't name them but
i i do believe that the nra which i
hoped wasn't as powerful as was stated
in the press was real
now the nra's power is not just about
money um you know they have a fairly
robust and active membership list their
endorsement has become a proxy for um
other issues beyond uh your position on
guns but they certainly do spend a lot
of money and that money has clearly just
in the last couple of weeks had an
impact on the public policy debate
but there are other indirect ways that
money impacts the debate i mean there
really are
very few quid pro quo's
where
a member of any legislative body is
accepting a political donation in
exchange for a vote it doesn't happen
that way and when it does you normally
get caught for it
but
it has an impact and
you know the drug industry is a perfect
example right the drug industry both
through its
connections via donations to candidates
and its layering of the united states
capital and state capitals with
lobbyists
essentially drowns out the other side of
that debate the other side of the drug
debate is
a completely unorganized side it's it's
it's
consumers
who are paying the highest drug prices
in
the world it's
low-income
healthcare beneficiaries who have
absolutely no way to exercise their
political power the
drug industry wins just seriously
just basically by overwhelming
congress and state legislators with
advocacy knowing that there's going to
be very little advocacy on the other
side and when you have to raise money
all the time and you have to spend time
sitting in cocktail party after cocktail
party with representatives of the
drug industry the insurance industry
even though you're not
casting a vote because of the
contribution they made you're just
hearing their argument over and over and
over again and money becomes a way to
get your argument in front of members of
the senate and members of the house of
representatives um
that's the indirect impact that it has
and the indirect impact is real
um third
the impact um
well let me actually make one more
comment on the impact on public policy
here's the
here's the potential way out um when it
comes to the impact on public policy and
that's the internet
there is another revolution happening
here which is that your reliance on
those contributions from special
interest groups
can be mitigated by an increasing
ability to crowdsource
political fundraising
and
while that was the way out for president
obama in 2008 he was essentially able to
fund an entire presidential campaign
without going to the traditional special
interest sources
that development has been slow to
translate to house and senate races
but it's getting there
in my race in 2012
i raised 10 million dollars overall i
raised 4 million of that from the
internet um and my average contribution
taking all the contributions together
was under a hundred dollars um and so i
raised 40 of my money in
2012 from
small
donations through the internet i started
with a email list that was
i think around 5 000
and i grew it over the course of the
campaign to over 100 000 people and it
is my expectation that if i do the work
of continuing to sort of maintain and
build that list
over the next six years
that i could perhaps fund two-thirds to
three-quarters of my race
if i run again in 2018
via the internet and so this is a really
interesting development because if you
are able to truly crowdsource
fundraising not just for presidential
races but for house and senate races
the impact of drug industry money or nra
money on the political debate in
washington um
you know doesn't vanish
but it becomes
uh
it becomes much less significant
so lastly before i take questions let me
um talk about
the impact on the tenor of the debate um
so i think if there's any panacea
uh to what ills washington with respect
to the partisan divide
campaign finance reform there are a lot
of reasons why public discourse has
degraded and you can talk about the way
the media covers politics you can talk
about how house districts are drawn to
essentially eradicate swing districts
those are all important contributing
factors the most important contributing
factor is the way in which money is
raised today
here's the fact
when i send out an fundraising email
talking about how bad the republicans
are
it raises on average three times as much
money
as when i send out an email fundraising
email talking about how good i am or how
good
the work that i do is
people are motivated to give
unfortunately
too often based on their fear of the
other side based on their support of
their side
and in an era in which you have to get
back to fundraising immediately after
the next election in order to raise
enough money to run yourself or to run
your party's campaigns
there is an immediate incentive to dig
trenches
after the last election in order to
raise
money for the next one and so there was
a lot of head scratching when mitch
mcconnell came out shortly after
president obama was elected and
said that his number one goal was
defeating president obama and that
seemed like an incredibly irresponsible
thing to to say but it also suggests it
seemed to
be
politically unsmart to a lot of people
uh as well um
the reality is
that that comment raised him and his
party a lot of money
and
if you were to remove the immediate need
to go back to the trough to raise money
you would remove a lot of the rationale
for this immediate line drawing that
happens
after every election um and i gotta tell
you um i'd be lying if i didn't say that
it isn't an instinct that all of us have
to check
i mean i
none of us are perfect and there is
there is always
even knowing i have a six-year term um
you get into this gut instinct of
drawing lines in order to rally your
political supporters that's hard to
ultimately
unwind
when i was first elected to the house of
representatives and i sort of saw this
awfulness from the inside when i first
went down to the house
democratic call room if you ever have
the opportunity to come down and see
this place you should
it's in the dnc building it's on the
second floor it's probably not easy to
get into
as an academic or a reporter but it is
exactly what you would imagine a
telemarketing office to look like it is
cubicle after cubicle after cubicle
probably 40 of them all in one room with
members of congress sitting there making
calls on an hourly basis um i decided to
tell people about it and i wrote an
op-ed for the hartford current in my
first year in the house of
representatives um entitled i didn't get
elected to be a fundraiser and i talked
about that room and i talked about the
amount of my day that was spent every
day fundraising and i caught hell for it
the number of letters to
the editor the number of nasty emails um
you know really ridiculing me for
talking about the fact that part of my
life as a member of congress was spent
um thinking about fundraising
was pretty overwhelming um but i have
always seen it as you know my mission to
try to expose this ugliness i think far
too many members of the house and senate
try to
quell it try to quiet it try to hide it
because they don't want people to know
how much of their time is spent doing
the political side of this business
i ran for the senate
um in part
because i was sick of doing it every two
years and i just couldn't foresee my
life for the next 10 years being caught
up in two-year electoral cycles
i have not made a fundraising call since
i've been in the united states senate
but i know it won't be too long before i
make my first
and the fact is it's not a six year
cycle in the senate luckily you get a
little bit of time off but it still
happens even too quickly over on our
side of the aisle we've got to fix it
you guys are going to talk about the
solutions today i'll give you the
experience of the problem
but connecticut is a place that can
point the way when i got to the state
legislature as a 25 year old i
introduced a bill to publicly finance
state elections in connecticut now it
wasn't my bill that eventually passed
but 10 years
later
on my way out the door to the house of
representatives i was able to vote on uh
a proposal which made connecticut uh one
of the first states in the nation to
publicly finance elections and i think
if you talk to people in hartford they
will tell you we have a cleaner
system of government in this state where
people run based on their ideas not
based on their ability to raise money
lobbyists though
have not been neutered but their
influence is much less than it was 10
years ago
and if we can do it here in connecticut
it's not impossible that we can do it at
the national level during the
2009-2010 session we had over 50 votes
for a clean elections bill in the united
states senate and we had around 200
votes in the house of representatives
and we didn't have enough to pass it
but
we aren't light years away from being
able to pass a elections reform law if
only three years ago we had 50 votes in
the senate and we were only about
a dozen votes away from getting it
passed in the house of representatives
it's not inconceivable that we can do it
again but we can only do it if policy
leaders are willing to stand up and tell
people the reality of what this job is
like under the current rules and so i
was thrilled when jacob asked me to come
here today to talk to you about it it is
going to be
coming off one of these races in which i
ran against uh a self-funder and i'm
happy to talk about that experience as
as as well it's sort of like a
six-month-long root canal um i uh um
i'm i'm i'm as i said uh i've become uh
from a proponent to a revolutionary on
these topics and the fact that you guys
are talking about it here today and
talking about paths forward uh makes me
feel a little bit better uh inside so
thank you very much for everyone for
having me today
i'd love to take some questions
um
is
on your side
and that
could be you know
great benefit for issues
well listen i don't want to sound like
i'm um living
up to um a different standard than
others are um you know i had super pac
money spent in this race um in 2012. um
i i had a handful of my friends start a
super pac um that spent money uh in this
race and so um i've always
you know i've always believed that
you argue to change the rules but you
live by them up until the point that you
uh that you changed them so um
so
step back to the 2012 elections how did
i feel when the super pac started
spending money in my race so that i was
at a you know five to one disadvantage
rather than an eight-to-one disadvantage
i've felt pretty good
um you know i mean i felt like you know
i was somebody was coming to get my back
um and i feel the same way about um
you know the impact that mike bloomberg
and gabby gifford's group is going to
have in the gun control debate um you
know i think the nra has been
advocating and spending money in an
absolute vacuum for the last 10 years so
it's no secret why they enjoy so much
power when people cast votes against the
nra they have
no confidence that someone is going to
get their back to defend their position
for the first time
in
the history of the debate over gun laws
people who take
a tough vote um against the nra are
going to have
going to have money at their at their
backs in the next election and i think
that's important
um and i don't deny that that's
important and frankly
under the current laws i'm going to
encourage my supporters to donate to the
you know gabby giffords group um in
order to make sure that there is some uh
political weight behind those who voted
with us um so
you know i don't see it as um trying to
have it both ways um i you know i um
you know i drive the speed limit while
you know arguing it for it to be five
miles higher um i'm gonna do the same
thing on camp and finance reform i'm
gonna be an active participant in trying
to raise money on our side to win this
fight with the nra but i'm also going to
argue that the rules should change so
that it doesn't have to be this
important
washington post um there was an
interesting pension i thought in your
remarks here which is on the one hand
you were talking about how the answer
could be
on the other hand the small donor
politics is highly polarized
i think people talk about that they have
this idea that this is somehow free
money in
specifically ideological one so given
that is that an answer i mean if it all
moved to internet uh fundraising
tomorrow you didn't have to take any of
the corporate money would we have uh
would we fix the system
no so i'm only identifying that as an
answer to the sort of second problem
which i identified which is the
importance of the sort of this
specifically organized special interest
in corporate money on politics it is a
solution to that um it is certainly not
a solution uh to the issue of
polarization um and and so the third
problem that identified which is the the
the import that fundraising has in the
tenor of debate does not get solved by
the democratization of fundraising
through uh through the internet um and
you know you can argue that it frankly
gets exacerbated by it because if the
only groups that are able to organize
small donor internet dollars are groups
that have access to grind on the right
or the left uh you know then it further
it potentially further pulls the uh the
debate away to either to either side so
ultimately the issue has to be the
public financing of elections i mean
that is the holy grail to which
to which i aspire um
the temporary salve on the wound it can
be internet financing because i think
that's ultimately
at least cures one of the current evils
um but ultimately you have to um
to say you can't amend the constitution
you've got to do everything within your
statutory and constitutional power to
move private financing to uh to to the
sidelines
i want to know what you thought about
commitments like senator
um
you know i i think it's i think it's i
think it's important but you know there
are just so many ways to get money to
candidates outside of organized packs uh
today that um you know that's that's
hard to be an answer in and of uh in and
of itself so um uh you know
i i think that um
i think that refusing to take pac money
is an important indicator that you're
serious about this problem um but
you know this this sort of
um issue based money is going to come
into your pocket no matter what and i
think we just have to admit that
i mean
everybody that's giving
is giving for a reason right i mean some
of them are your family and your friends
who just are giving to you because they
trust your judgment but most people are
giving money because they care about an
issue whether they are a corporation or
an individual
and
you know we i think you know at times we
risk drawing arbitrary lines
by suggesting that some of those
donations
are ethically questionable and others
aren't um
you know corporations want things from
government but so do individuals
nearly everyone that gives gives with an
axe to grind and so again
it's a reason for me why we need
revolutionary change why you can't just
sort of change the rules of the game
remember pacs were set up
as a campaign finance reform i mean they
were supposed to be a means to sort of
make more transparent
corporate donations and and channel them
in a way that people could see and
control
i just think that the
the way to solve this is ultimately to
reduce the reliance on
private financing writ large whether it
comes from individuals or
uh
or political action committees because
they they they both come
with certain expectations and strings
attached
mm-hmm
nate london from the law school here
yeah uh thank you for your remarks uh
this self-funded thing seems to cut both
ways i mean in the world in which we
have yet to recharge the holy grail of
public financing obviously finding your
own campaign insulates you from
particular interest in a way that's
probably almost impossible to do without
being self-funded so and but having gone
through the recent campaign i'd be
interested to hear your reflections on
that yeah i'm biased on this one um no i
mean you're right you're right i mean
there is
that that has always been the case with
self-funders and i mean i can't say it
any better than than than you did um
you know it certainly um
uh certainly is beneficial to come to
office you know owing you know no one
and i think you know bloomberg is an
example of someone who's been able to um
you know do some pretty important things
because he's not necessarily worried
about the implications on his
fundraising for the next uh elections um
but um
but you know the senate is already a
millionaires club um
you know we just we just risk if if
self-funding is the only means by which
you get into office we risk you know our
elected leadership looking totally
different than the rest of the of the
public um and so ultimately i think that
the
downside to having um governance by the
elites um greatly outweighs the freedom
uh that comes
with election without contribution
yeah
uh
okay you say that in the microphone
we've got a good one here i said i think
anyway but i think chris has been
principled on these issues and on all
other issues for a very very long time
so i want to say thank you chris
second point just to add a little color
commentary and this is and this will
lead to the question one point you
didn't make about the fundraising uh the
the debilitating aspects of the
fundraising are the way in which it
creates the sense among the candidates
who are doing the fundraising that the
issues that the people who are giving
big money to campaigns
are the issues of the country uh and my
own experience was you know doing the
dialing for dollars for team that you
just talked about
you know getting a list of some of
another congressman's
thousand dollar contributors
going into one of those cubicles calling
all day long
and since my point was my goal was to
get the money not to persuade someone
that their views on welfare cheats are
on tax reform or in gotcha environmental
regulations was the was you know that
their views were wrong
over the course of the night you could
feel yourself starting to say well you
know
people were saying outrageous things
and over the course of the evening
you're starting to say you know you have
a point where if you'll hope help me get
elected i'd love to have you come down
and we'll talk about it you know but
it's but by the end nobody nobody on
that evening said i'm having trouble
finding daycare for my children or i'm
having trouble paying for my basic
expenses everybody said my business
taxes are too high environmental
regulations are too tough other people
are getting away with murder and just
seems to me that it just makes what the
issues of the debate are um
tremendously skewed and i'm just wanting
you to comment on that yeah no i mean i
listen i talked a lot more about carried
interest inside that call room than i
did at the supermarket
right i mean
right it's true i mean it's it's it's
true you're lo you know um so who do you
call right i mean who do you call
especially when you know you can raise
um the low donor money online you know
your call time is
geared towards people who have the
ability
to give
for a senate race
thousand dollars or more right so for a
house race i would call somebody that
would give me 250 for a senate race i'm
not calling anybody who doesn't have the
chance of giving me at least a thousand
dollars i mean that's not i mean i i'm
economically comfortable i'm not in a
position to give someone who calls me a
thousand dollars um based on that
conversation so you got to imagine that
the people i'm calling you know are
folks that are you know making a half a
million do a million dollars and you
know uh they have fundamentally
different problems than uh everybody uh
everybody else so yeah you spend um and
in connecticut especially right
connecticut you spend a lot of time on
the phone with people who work in the
financial markets um and so you're
hearing a lot about
you know problems that you know bankers
have and not a lot of problems that uh
people who work at the mill in thomaston
connecticut have um and you know that um
and you certainly you certainly have to
stop and and and check yourself and
listen if you live you know and
if you know that i live in connecticut
so i'm back here every weekend and i um
you know i make sure that i do go to the
grocery store and i do set up my card
table outside the shopping plaza to hear
from people so i mean i you know go out
of my way to try to be proactive in the
way that i interact with my constituents
in part because i know that what that
when i've been raising money i'm not
hearing from a representative sample
senator i am very mindful of your time
yeah
yeah one more question go ahead yeah
yeah go ahead
hi blair bowie with the u.s public
interest research group um so i'm
curious about
your specific stance on what the best
public financing proposal would look
like as you know there's a wide spectrum
of proposals everything from just
getting a lump sum even to both
candidates or
getting matches based on the number of
small donors you can get to give per se
so uh what do you think is the best
scheme and why
so you know again i mean i'm prejudicial
in this respect but i i think that
connecticut's to me is the model i think
connecticut has sort of gone has bumped
up as close to constitutionality as you
can get in terms of its aggressiveness
so we have a
system by which you have to raise a
certain number of small
donations
upon which you
qualify for a substantial
grant in public funds it is not a
matching system uh i think you have to
raise
you know a couple thousand dollars at
the state legislative level in order to
get twenty five thousand dollars you
have to raise a couple hundred thousand
in
funds for the governor's race in order
to qualify for six million dollars so um
and and ultimately um i think that our
system has shown that um
the
threshold amounts are still serious
enough that you have to go out and do
work and build a broad base of support
it's
you can't qualify overnight you really
have to spend months at receiving those
small
dollar donations but upon the moment
that you do that
fundraising a lim is eliminated from
your calendar um and that was a big
benefit in the last election dan malloy
is our governor today having run against
two cell funders who operated outside of
that system so some people say
public finance isn't going to work
because you can't eliminate the ability
of somebody to work outside of that
system well that is true but in alton
connecticut is a democratic state but
2010 was not a great year for democrats
to be running anywhere and our system
showed that we were able to get enough
money in public financing to the
democratic candidate such that he could
survive running against a self-funder
both in the democratic primary and in
the general election because he had
enough money and that's kind of what
happened in my race as well i didn't
have public financing but um
the input there is a diminishing
marginal return to uh to campaign
spending um you know my candidate you
know linda mcmahon in 2012 was one of
the few who actually hit the tipping
point right i mean who who saw a you
know decreasing marginal return from her
spending at some point um but you know
once you in a senate race in a place
like connecticut once you get over
12 to 15 you know once you get over 15
million dollars you know the the
increase in utility you're getting is
smaller and smaller so as long as your
public grant
actually
reflects the true cost of running
elections which ours in connecticut do
at the statewide level
then they can work clearly what happened
in the presidential uh system was that
they they didn't the the matching funds
just did not end up reflecting what the
true cost of running a presidential race
was and so if you want a
good public financing system you have to
have the ability of your grant to change
we actually i mean amazingly in
connecticut
we did that in the middle of the 2010
election we realized having this is the
first time that we had done it we
realized in the middle of the 2010
election the grant that damilow was
getting was not going to be enough
given the cost of running both a primary
and a in a general um
and so they increased the
the the the grant but you've got to have
that flexibility built in all right
thank you very much